من عمان تنضم الينا يا رولا الامين
المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا سيده رولا مرحله مرحبا بك
معنا الان الى اين وصلتم في تقييم حجم
الدمار والاضرار ومدى الحاجه الى مساعدات
في المناطق السوريه المنكوبه
طبعا حجم الاضرار والخسائر يزداد مع كل
يوم ونتوقع المزيد من الارقام الدقيق عن
حجم هذه الخسائر ولكن حضرتك تعلم ان
الكثير من المناطق التي قد تاثرت هي في
مناطق بعيده ويصعب الوصول اليها وللاسف
الكثير من العائلات ما زالت تحاول انقاذ
احبائها واقاربها لوحدها
المؤسسات الانسانيه كالمفوضيه تحاول
الوصول الى كل من يحتاج الى المساعده نحن
مثلا داخل سوريا
المنطق التي نستطيع الوصول اليها ارسلنا
مواد اغاثيه كالخيام اقمشه بلاستيكيه
بطانيات ما هي هذه المناطق التي وصلتم
اليها
من هناك منطقتين انت تعلم في سوريا هناك
المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره الحكومه ونحن ايضا
موجودون فيها ووصلنا الى حلب
طرطوس اللاذقيه لدينا شركاء الارض وهم
يحاولون الوصول هؤلاء طبعا الاحتياجات
ايضا كبيره هناك لان ليس فقط الخسائر كانت
بالارواح والمباني التي تعدمت ولكن من بقي
ايضا على قيد الحياه انت تعرف هناك اعداد
كبيره من الجرحى الكثير من الناس كانت
تسكن في بنايات ربما متضرره من الحرب اصلا
واصبحت بعد الزلزال لا تصلح لكن ليست
للسكن وهم الان بدون ماوى هناك يعني مقاوم
جماعيه تقام ونحاول المساعده هناك بتقديم
كل هذه الغازيه ولكن لماذا بخصوص المناطق
الخاضعه ربما لسيطره المعارضه كيف
تتعاملون معه
هذه النقطه الثانيه ايضا هناك
الخسائر جدا كبيره كما تعلم هناك
المعظم الموجودين هناك ايضا هم نازحون
قد هربوا من منازلهم وانتقلوا من مكان الى
اخر على مدى السنوات الماضيه يعيشون اما
في خيام او في بيوت جدا هشه وقد تاثروا
بالزلزال هناك من فقد حياتهم من فقد بيته
وايضا هنا من لم يفقد اي من هؤلاء لا
يستطيع العوده الى البيت الذي كان يسكنه
بسبب الاضرار هناك حاجه للماوى هناك حاجه
للغذاء هناك حاجه للمعدات وطبعا جهود
الاغاثه لاستخلاص الجثث او من بقي حيا حتى
الان ايضا يعني هي اولويه ولكن للاسف فان
الزلزال
والطقس البارد جدا والعواصف الثلجيه قد
تشكل تحديا كبيرا من الوصول الى الجميع
كما تعلم معظم الاغاثات الانسانيه التي
تاتي الى الشمال الغربي سوريا تاتي عبر
تركيا من باب الهوى ولكن للاسف الطريق
الرئيسي الذي يصل هذا يعني تستخدمه
الشاحنات والسيارات الكبيره هذا الطريق
الرئيسي قد تدم يعني قد تم تدميره او تضرر
كثيرا بسبب الزلزال والعواصف الثلجيه ايضا
اغلقت طرق الاخرى وليس لا يوجد كهرباء ولا
يوجد انترنت فهذا كله اي اتصالات باي
اطراف على الارض هناك لتقييم صلاه ولكن مع
من تتصلون
سرعه زياده الامدادات الى هناك ليست
بالحاجه المطلوبه يعني الحاجه كبيره ويجب
ان يكون الامدادات تاتي بسرعه اكبر ولكن
هناك تحديات طبعا نحن كمفوضيه وكامم
المتحده لدينا مخزون من الخيام والبطانيات
والطعام داخل منطقه شمال غرب سوريا موجوده
في المخازن ولكنها ليست كافيه امام هذه
الفاجاه لذلك هناك حاجه ماسه لاصلاح هذا
الطريق بسرعه
تقول غير ذلك لا تقول ان المعبر جاهز
مفتوح جاهز لاستقبال اي مساعدات لكن لا
مؤشرات على اي مساعدات وصلت او تصل حتى
الان يعني من اي طرف كان
اداره معبر باب الهوى
البعبر مفتوح ولكن طرق ولكن الطرق خاصه في
الجانب التركي قد تضررت يعني نحن لدينا
تركات وشاحنات محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه حتى
قبل الزلزال كانت قد وصلت الى باب الهوى
وحتى الان علق هناك هذا قبل الزلزال حدث
الزلزال وتضرر الطريق ولم تعرف هذه
الشاحنات الوصول الان نحن نامل انه مع غدا
او يعني على الاقصى يوم الجمعه صباحا
سيكون هذا الطريق قد اصلح ولكن لدينا
بخصوص المعابر الاخرى يتم الحديث عن باب
السلامه يتم الحديث عن الراعي ومعابر اخرى
بديله ماذا بخصوص
خلينا يعني افتح لي المجال هذا استخدام
هذه المعابر ليس بيد المؤسسات الانسانيه
والاغاثيه كمفوضيه اللاجئين انت تعلم
الوضع في سوريا منذ سنوات مجلس الامن
الضحيه لمنظمات الامم المتحده لاستخدام
عابر من تركيا ومن الاردن لايصال
المساعدات للمناطق التي تخضع سيطره
المعارضه ولكن خلال السنوات الماضيه وفي
مجلس الامن خلال السنوات الماضيه تم تقليص
هذا
من المجلس الامن لا يفوت الاشخاص من الامم
المتحده بالدخول ولكن فقط بارسال المساعده
هناك اليات متفق عليها ويعمل فيها منذ
سنوات لادخال المساعدات بحيث تضمن الدقه
والعداله في التوزيع
المحاسبه يعني المحاسبه امام الذين يمولون
نحن وزعنا كذا وكذا من خلال شركاء موجودون
على الارض من منظمات دوليه ومحليه وسوق
معظمهم سوريون موجودون على الارض الا يتم
التفكير باي استثناءات باي طرق بديله اخرى
لمساعده هؤلاء الناس الذين يعني يعيشون
ماساه فوق ماساتهم التي يعيشونها اصلا
يعني المعارضه الان تتحدث بان كارثه
الزلزال هي اكبر من قدرتنا على
الاستيعاب في ظل يعني كلام من اكثر من جهه
بريطانيا الحكم البريطانيه تتحدث عن
مساعده ستوجهها الى المناطق التي تخضع
للمعارضه الولايات المتحده تحدثت عن
تدابير كذلك كفيله بهذا الامر قبل قليل
هناك اشاره على ان وفد مصري تقني طبي وصل
الى هذه المناطق لا ندري كيف وصل ليس
بامكان الهيئه او غيرها من الجهات ان تتخذ
اي طريق لتقديم هذه المساعده لهؤلاء الناس
يعني احنا خلينا نكون واقعيين انت تعلم
منظمات الامم المتحده تعمل حسب اليات
وقوانين ارسقه الامم المتحده والدول
الموجوده في المتحده بما فيها امريكا وبما
فيها بريطانيا قوانين الامم المتحده تمنع
هنا المنظمات الاغاثيه من عبور الحدود من
معابر غير شرعيه هذا بالعموم في اي دوله
الوضع في سوريا استدعى استثناء خلال
السنوات الماضيه ومجلس الامن اقر الصلاحيه
باستخدام هذا المعبر وهذا ما يجيز لنا
يعني استعماله لذلك نحن
ندعو الجميع بما فيهم بريطانيا وبما فيهم
امريكا وبما فيهم روسيا وجميع الاطراف
التي لها نفوز نحن نقول لندع السياسه
جانبا لنضع الاهداف السياسيه جانبا واللعب
السياسي جانبا ونركز على الاحتياجات الجمه
لهؤلاء الذين لا يستطيعون الانتظار ريثما
يتم التلاعب في الشعب حتى نسجل نقاط
المطلوب الان ايجاد اليه سريعه حتى نستوضح
الصوره
خلال هذا الوقت منذ بدايه هذا الزلزال
وبعد اول تصريح لك هل تغير في واقع الامر
شيء هل جرت اي اتصالات مع الناس او الجهات
التي تتحكم في المعبر مع الجاه سواء كان
النظام سواء كانت تركيا سلطات التركيه
سواء كانت الولايات المتحده او روسيا او
ايا كان هل جرت اي اتصالات الان اي تقدم
في في في فكره ايصال المساعدات باي طريقه
كانت
نعم
اورا المشكله ان المساعدات الاضافيه
عالقه بسبب تضرر الطريق طريق الشاحنات
وليس بسبب اي عائق سياسي في اداره المعبر
يعني هذا ليس هو السبب وليس هو نحن نامل
ان هذا الطريق سيفتح والمزيد من المساعدات
سيدخل ولكن في الاثناء هناك مساعدات
موجوده في المخازن داخل شمال غرب سوريا
وشركائنا لديهم قدره على الوصول اليها
واصالها ولكن الاحتياجات كبيره يعني انت
المراسلون والزملاء الموجودون في الميدان
ينقلون صور مروعه طيب
موجود مصري يعني على الارض الان في مناطق
المعارضه كيف وصلوا
لان الوفد المصري لا يخضع لنفس الاليات
والقوانين التي تخضع لها مؤسسات الامم
المتحده والتي اقرتها الدول الموجوده في
الامم المتحده يعني اي دوله في العالم لا
تسمح بان تقوم بافراد من الامم المتحده
بعبور الحدود الغير بدون موافقتها هذا
يعني هذه قوانين دوليه
الوفد المصري تجاوز هذا الامر ربما كان
هناك اتفاق مع الحكومه السوريه ربما كان
هناك انا لا اعرف تفاصيل والسؤال هنا يعني
هل هناك طريقه لنفس السيناريو يعني من قبل
هذه المفوضيه او الجهه نعم ان تقوم بنفس
الطريقه فقط
ما الذي ترمي اليه ولكن والله لا ارمي الى
اي شيء انا اشاهد كما تشاهدون
اشاهد كما تشاهدون يعني الوضع هو اسوا
بالتاكيد في المناطق السوريه الغير خاضعه
لسيطره النظام في ظل ضعف الامكانيات في
ضمن اصلا المباني مهترئه ومهدمه وهي قايله
للسقوط جراء القصف والضربات والدماغ الذي
كيف ستكون المصيبه هناك وفي ظل حتى شح
المعلومات شوح التقارير شح البيانات نتحدث
فقط الان اليس هناك من طريقه سريعه تحاول
باي شكل كان الوصول الى هؤلاء الناس الان
حسب التقارير وحسب العاجل يعني وفاه في كل
خمسين دقيقه يعني
انا اسف
في طريقه ونحن نعمل عليها كما قلت لك
لدينا شركاء على الارض هم شركائنا من خلال
كل السنوات الماضيه في تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه داخل شمال غرب سوريا وهم الذين
يوزعون المساعدات سواء للمفوضيه او
ليونيسف او هم هم المسؤولون عن توزيع هذه
المساعدات وهم موجودون على الارض ولكن
هناك زلزال وهناك عواصف ثلجيه وهم يحاولون
الوصول الى الجميع ولكن هناك معوقات نحن
نعمل بكافه الطرق لتجاوز هذه المعوقات
وندعو الجميع الى رمي السياسه جانبا
والتركيز على احتياجات هؤلاء الناس وارجو
من الجميع ومن حضرتك يعني المقارنه بين
اين من تضرر اكثر غير لائقه الجميع قد
تضرر هذه مباني هدمت على عائلات باكملها
المدنيه لكن هناك تفاوت في طريقه المعالج
بينما مناطق واخرى بين مليون في سوريا
دفعوا الثمن الاكبر لهذه الازمه ولا يجوز
ان نفرق بينهم الاحتياجات الانسانيه هي
ذاتها يجب ان نساعد كل من يحتاج ان
تفهميني فقط ارجو ان تفهمين فقط انا لا
افرق بين انا اقول ان هناك اطراف حتى الان
يعانون من عدم وصول اي مساعدات باي نوع
يعني فقط هذا هو
ليس صحيحا ان المساعدات لم تصل نحن لدينا
مخازن في شمال غرسونيه ولدينا شركاء على
الارض وهم يعني لديهم شبكه واسعه لتوزيع
المساعدات والوصول الى الناس ولكن الوضع
صعب جدا الوضع صعب جدا حتى في تركيا هذا
الزلزال كبير هذا زلزالين كبيرين مع
ارتدادات كثيره لا اعرف ما الذي تريد ان
ترمي الى اي شيء يا سيدتي لكني انا اراقب
المشهد والموقف في كثير من المناطق
اعطيتك فرصه سيدتي فقط حتى انا اطرح عليك
السؤال وثم اعطيك المجال لتجيبي كما
تريدين بدون تشنج بدون يعني
والله مش متفنج انا بسالك فقط بطرح السؤال
المنطقي الذي يطرح من كل مكان ونركز على
مساعده الناس ونركز على الجميع يجب ان
الجميع يجب ان يهب لمساعده هؤلاء الناس
اينما كانوا هؤلاء الناس في محنه 12 سنه
وهم يعانون من الحرب ومن الازمات
الاقتصاديه ومن جائحه كوفيد ومن ترك
العالم لهم ومن نسيان العالم لهم الازمه
السوريه ليست فقط سوريا الكل كان له دور
فيها
ليس انا من قال بان المساعدات لم تصل
السوريون الموجودون الان على الارض في
المناطق هم قالوا ذلك كل ساعه تاخير حسب
هذه الفرق في ايصال المساعدات تقابلها 50
وفاء هم يتحدثون عن عدم وصول اي مساعدات
له من اي طرف كان من اي محبر كان من
المعابر المفتوحه وغير المفتوحه على كل
حال نقدر لك ما ذكرته يقدر لك كل الجهد
التي تقوم به شكرا جزيلا لك على تواجدك
معنا رولا الامين المتحدث باسم المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا من عمان